[Music]
now that daniel craig has finally earned
some time to die revisit the six
canonical films of the best damn
james not you bond ever
doesn't count
every connery bond
sean connery stars as james bond
england's most scottish spy i'm a very
nervous passenger a secret agent who was
already too over this by a second outing
whatever you say old man but james
brings a unique set of skills to the
table like being famous my god you just
killed james bond
disguise fighting like your drunk
stepdad
and being one of the all-time greatest
baccaratters
baccaratists back red guys
yeah no clue what's going on here this
game might as well be quidditch
james won't bond alone joining him is m
a character you could easily replace
with a self-destructing tape player from
mission impossible q the only mad
scientist on bonsai
who gives him every gadget from
chekhov's poison briefcase to chekhov's
helicopter briefcase
miss moneypenny proof that mi6 may have
an m and a q but it's definitely missing
an h in an r next time i see you i'll
put you across my knee on yogurt and
lemon juice
i can hardly wait and whichever lucky
girl james traps on his sex boat at the
end of each film they can't refuse
because of the implication but no matter
how great the risk if you help james
bond accomplish his mission he will
never let you get killed don't worry
cuddle everything's going to be fine
okay maybe once see you in the
restaurant
they killed each other once or twice you
wanted to ask me some questions
okay constantly
oh hey it almost looked like you cared
about her oh you know what that's called
character growth
set off on your typical connery bond
adventure that begins with a lounge
singer bursting a blood vessel
before globetrotting from the bluest
depths of the ocean to some of the most
exotic locales you can pretend to drive
through where bond will track the bad
guy to their bachelor pad of evil quip
on the stillwarm grave of their henchmen
oh he blew a fuse
then take down the real threat a rich
european man with the physique of an egg
this is the ideal evil body you may not
like it but this is what peak evil
performance looks like
in between all the classic moments you
remember do you expect me to talk no mr
bond i expect you to die
settle in for all the classic busy work
you forgot these old movies were full of
as you joined bond on a marathon of
exciting meetings briefings and
interviews the prime minister and the
president
have talked together over the hotline
and
have agreed that unless the bombs are
recovered
payment will have to be made watch him
meticulously secure his bedrooms
[Music]
get driving directions you leave the
port royal road out of kingston then
along the windwood road until you get to
the cement factory then you turn left
follow the road up the hill down the
other side and two miles
and check into his hotel we're here to
make you stay as pleasant as possible
that's really most kind of you do we
really need this part
your room is ready we do my key it's 304
please thank you again good night the
night was bombed
well i think it's about hotel time
why
return to a time where everyone was a
drunken chainsmoker so it didn't take
too much to knock him out cold
[Music]
to the point where being a sober incel
gave you superpowers vargas does not
drink
does not smoke
does not make love and watch james take
on spectre the vegans of crime and that
it's only a matter of time before they
let you know that they're inspector i'm
a member of spectre special executive
for counter intelligence terrorism
revenge extortion i'm now working for
spectrum spectre always delivers what it
promises welcome to spectre island these
illuminati's have an evil plan to
disrupt the space program steal nuclear
missiles and
well they just kind of ping pong between
those two plans there's a real brain
drain when you keep killing your
co-workers
this is why spacex will never get to
mars
bond may have a license to kill
but it's the bond girls who give him a
license to say
every girl jinx meets along the way has
the shape of an hourglass and the name
of a drag queen sylvia trench plenty of
tools [ __ ] color honey ryden
what's so funny about it and whether
they get to be a character with their
own motives and agenda or a sexy baby
who just kind of washes up on shore bond
will get them into bed with little more
than a look all the things i do for
england
except for the times when he has to
force them
[Music]
or blackmail them i'd lose my job i
suppose my silence could have a prize
you don't mean
and that's before he smacks them around
a little
though how much of this is bond and how
much is connery we'll never know i think
it's absolutely right
to give a good slap yeah absolutely
yikes
so enjoy this iconic defender of the
empire responsible for most of the
world's problems in an english fantasy
where they're still at the center of
geopolitics as we salute this heroic
dinosaur who simply refuses to go
extinct no matter how many times he
should have been killed by spectre
or liver disease i told the stewardess
liquor for three who are the other two
oh there are no other two or chlamydia
they're both yours or parody yeah baby
yeah
or bankruptcy unfortunately they ran out
of money or swedish humping machine
[Music]
or just plain older robins that's as bad
as listening to the beatles
we all keep coming back for more and by
more i mean lazenby then connery then
more craig brosnan dalton yeah that's my
ranking fight me
starring
me two below seven
judy dench origins tinker taylor older
guy
simpat
dr no
daniel craig i love gold
blow hard you can't play his odd job
he's shorter that's cheating
dick fury
fellas is it gay to try to assassinate
james bond with your bros soviet vehicle
physics
[Music]
bad editing he was right you know
what is it i'll show you
[Music]
nature you scary waits until the
survivor is so exhausted that he cannot
defend himself
you will see that my piranha fish get
very hungry
[Music]
you know how i know you're an alcoholic
i'd say it was a 30 year old fiend
indifferently blended sir
with an overdose of bomb
51 i believe there is no year for chevy
double 07. i was referring to the
original vintage and which the sharia is
based 1851. unstickable i like saki
especially when it's served at the
correct temperature
98.4 degrees fahrenheit like this
and kobe
[Music]
for my next miracle i
the spy who [ __ ] me
[Music]
okay so what's up with the gun barrel
opening i know it's a classic but like
is that what a bullet sees before it
fires and if the guy holding the gun
gets shot why do i see blood dripping
down if we're inside the gun
so how much has this dinosaur changed
since the 60s we tracked the evolution
of the james bond franchise from connery
to craig in a breezy little jet pack
ride through bond history click the
thumbnail on the right to watch now
everything all of sean connery in honor
of the original james bond
i say i say i say
hello sydney it's an honor
your mom is green
what would scooby dooby dooby doo do
you're my snickerdoodle
we have all the time in the world